FOX NEWS MEDIA ANALYST AND A
HOST OF THE FOX MEDIA BUZZ
HOWARD KURTZ IS LOOKING AT HOW
SOCIAL MEDIA CAN LEAD TO
DISASTER, NO MATTER WHO YOU ARE.
>> EVERYONE HAS AN OPINION ON
ABC'S CANCELLATION OF THE
ROSEANNE BARR SHOW, AND TODAY
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF JOINED THE
FRAY.
RATHER THAN ASSESS BARS RACIST
TWEET, THE PRESIDENT TWEETED
THAT DISNEY CEO BOB IGER CALLED
VALERIE JARRETT TO LET HER KNOW
THAT ABC DOESN'T TOLERATE
COMMENTS LIKE THOSE MADE BY
ROSEANNE BARR.
GEE, HE NEVER CALLED PRESIDENT
DONALD J. TRUMP TO APOLOGIZE
ABOUT THE HORRIBLE STATEMENTS
MADE BY ME.
IT MAY BE I JUST DIDN'T GET THE
CALL.
THIS FOLLOWED A BIZARRE TWEET
STORM OVERNIGHT IN WHICH BARR
RIPPED HER CRITICS, APOLOGIZED
AND BLAMED SLEEP MEDICATION.
GUYS, IT WAS TOO IN THE MORNING
AND I WAS AMBIEN TWEETING.
IT WAS EGREGIOUS.
>> THAT PROMPTED THE DRUG
MANUFACTURER TO DECLARE THAT
RACISM IS NOT A SIDE EFFECT OF
ANY SANOFI MEDICATION.
NOW HBO IS BEING SAID TO BOOT
BELMAR FOR ONCE COMPARING
TRUMP'S HAIR TO AN ORANGUTAN.
CNN FIRED A HOST FOR TWEETING
THAT TRUMP WAS A PIECE OF S, AN
EMBARRASSMENT TO HUMANKIND.
SHE ALSO FIRED JEFFREY LORD FOR
TWEETING THE SALUTE.
TOOK NO ACTION AGAINST FORMER
"SPORTSCENTER" HOST FOR TWEETING
THAT TRUMP IS A WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
SHE WAS LATER SUSPENDED FOR
SUGGESTING THAT THE
DALLAS COWBOYS BE SUSPENDED OVER
PLAYER PROTEST.
SHE ADMITTED THESE TWEETS WERE
DOMINANT HATEFUL.
TRUMP'S HAS ALSO DRAWN FLAK AND
THAT WAS YESTERDAY'S UNPROVEN
CHARGED THAT ROBERT MUELLER WAS
A MEDDLING WITH THE MIDTERMS.
HE ALSO PUNCHES BACK AGAINST
VICIOUS CRITICISM.
>> TWITTER ERUPTS SO QUICKLY